from exclusive items to portion sizes in
order to find out all the differences
between Ikea food in the US and the UK
this is food Wars
quick note it turns out Ikea does not
offer a takeout option but fortunately
they do sell lots of Tupperware
containers so in case you're wondering
why the food looks a little bit sad it's
because we had to improvise on with the
video Let's Start portion sizes with
Ikea's claim to fame when it comes to
food the Swedish meatballs in the US
Ikea's restaurant offer only one portion
size for meatballs eight pieces but
after that you can get them in
increments of four for instance
12 meatballs in the UK Ikea's iconic
meatballs come in two portion sizes
eight or twelve you can also add 4 extra
meatballs to any order for an extra one
pound 75 and there's seemingly no limit
to how many times you can do this in the
UK the meatballs come with either mashed
potatoes or chips on the side as well as
some Garden peas lingonberry jam and of
course their famous gravy and of course
the meatball options all come with a
side of mashed potatoes and peas get a
load of that also a little bit of
cranberry sauce we're gonna wear eight
meatballs in both countries to see whose
meatballs are bigger
[Music]
let's also try and weigh our Mash now I
do feel like the stats might be skewed
slightly because there's some peas
embedded in this I will try and free it
where I can
we got way more mash than the UK like
almost double
they're feeding us at our Ikeas vegans
and vegetarians Rejoice Ikea also offers
vegetarian vegan versions of its
meatballs right here we're doing a blank
taste test plant versus meat
that's definitely plant-based what's the
next one
oh was that wrong wait okay well give me
another one okay this is the other one
not even close thank you Peter neither
were bad and if I was a vegetarian or
vegan I would be perfectly happy with
those plant food tasted perfectly fine
but
that the the difference is noticeable we
share a couple of dessert options with
the US notably the dime cake over here
we call that the caramel almond cake
let's weigh a slice
another dessert option we share with the
UK is a soft serve ice cream which you
get in vanilla or strawberry okay first
of all the gentleman who worked there
was adamant that's actually frozen
yogurt I don't know if that's true or
not regardless they didn't have to-go
cups like Harry was able to get so all
they would give us is like the small cup
where it's kind of poking out like it's
ready to eat it is 97 degrees in Los
Angeles today there's absolutely no way
that I was making up from Ikea to the
car let alone the studio so here's
footage of me enjoying it in the lobby
of Ikea so I'm sorry I didn't bring the
scale I don't know how much it weighs we
have soft serve ice cream in the UK too
either as vanilla or vanilla with
chocolate sauce impressively they've
given us exactly 100 grams of soft serve
ice cream Ikea is also known for its hot
dogs in the UK you can get either a
classic hot dog or a veggie hot dog from
The Bistro stand we're going to measure
and weigh the classic hot dog to compare
with the US
the hot dog in the UK is seven inches in
length and with the toppings of pickles
and onions it weighs 114 grams hot dog
five and a quarter inches long and our
hot dog weighs 75 grams
here are all the menu items from a UK
Ikea that you won't find in the US
here's all the food you'll find in a U.S
Ikea you won't find in the UK starting
out down here
hot entrees this single piece of chicken
is the Havana chicken that doesn't come
alone it comes with plantains rice and
beans which we'll see in a little bit
but just isolated the chicken has been
sitting for a minute sorry Havana
chicken I wonder what makes it so Havana
yeah then again some spices in here very
flavorful
not just like a standard piece of
chicken it's actually really good we'll
start down this end with some main
courses we have two different non-meat
meatball options in the UK firstly we
have the veggie balls these are
meatballs which are formed of ground up
vegetables and they're also served with
a vegetable couscous as well but for
vegetarians who prefer something a bit
more reminiscent of meat they also have
plant balls now I'm kind of intrigued by
these because they look really good
these are a fake meat version of Ikea's
classic meatballs now compared to a
classic meatball they're actually like
almost more visually appealing I would
say they're a nice dark golden brown
color they look like they've you know
been cooked in a similar way maybe even
kind of like fried or cooked for longer
than you would expect from these let's
do a very quick taste test classic
meatball
we all know and love it these things are
delicious and then one of the plant
bowls
I will say the plant-based one doesn't
have that distinct Ikea meatball taste
to it that said still pretty tasty I
think texture wise it's like almost
identical to the classic meatball you
can also get a salmon fillet with pea
pesto vegetable medallions and a corn
medley which you can see right here I
mean Salmon's okay I guess okay this
isn't it's been sitting for a while if
you like salmon sure
is interesting though still in the mood
for fish
Before You Go furniture shopping you can
also get the garlic lemon cod with of
course mashed potatoes and peas extra
that's a pretty good piece of fish you
actually really like that
okay I stand corrected I was distant I
was dissing The Fish they're actually
pretty good we have a British classic
dish and that's fish and chips now the
fish they serve at Ikea in the UK is
pollock it comes with chips peas and
some tartar sauce now unlike fish and
chips that you might find from a classic
chippy in the UK they've actually
breaded their fish rather than battered
and then fried it I generally prefer the
battered fish texture I like the kind of
crispy crunch on the outside that you
get from batter I'm gonna have a little
little try of this it's very weird
tasting things on food Wars using a back
and Fork I don't like it
I respect that they have attempted to
localize their menu to the UK Market but
maybe you have a bit more thought into
your iron leader if you want to see what
proper fish and chips looks like go and
check out our Food Tours best fish and
chips in London video next up we have
another fish option it's a salmon fillet
next up we have another fish option it's
a salmon fillet in the UK we generally
lean more towards Philip as the wording
and also we spell it slightly
differently often we spell it with two
L's words I believe in the US tends to
be spelled with one I think you can get
a salmon fillet in the U.S however like
we say we pronounce ours slightly
differently and also in the UK ours
comes with the veggie couscous chicken
tenders
on the fries and broccoli
red
these tenders are actually very good
like the breading they're really breaded
decent fries hearty Ikea also has a few
things on the menu that were not
available at the one we went to a
chicken thigh with garlic chipotle sauce
broccoli and rice sounds actually pretty
good Lincoln Berry barbecue ribs with
mac and cheese ah I was so mad they
didn't have those and a plant-based
burger with fries also not available at
China filming this now Lincoln berries
are majorly popular in Swedish Cuisine
and you're going to see them pop up a
few more times in the Ikea menu next up
is penne pasta with tomato sauce penne
of course refers to the shape of pasta
that they use here in Ikea
Charlie's love that
I think penny is maybe my least favorite
pasta shape
I do not respect Penny moving swiftly on
from the penne we have a chicken katsu
curry I think this is like a relatively
new addition to the UK Ikea menu so
katsu refers to the chicken katsu fillet
which is a breaded and fried piece of
chicken and then it's served with rice
and katsu sauce I've not tried this
before
that looks like one just massive piece
of chicken you know
in science other than a couple of like
slightly disconcerting dark patches
inside the chicken breast it's actually
not bad I think because of the size of
the breast it's dried out quite a lot
but the katsu sauce is really nice I
like it with the rice I think
particularly if we're eating this hot
this actually would be pretty good next
up on the UK menu you can find a potato
and cauliflower Rogan Josh Curry a Rogan
Josh is a curry that you'll find on the
menu of a lot of UK Curry houses it's
not super spicy generally quite mild I'd
say traditionally you would see this
made with lamb but they've made a
vegetarian version here obviously with
potato and cauliflower as the main bulk
of it the Rogan Josh from Ikea is served
with rice and you can also get some side
options which are designed to go with it
including some pakoras samosas and a
garlic naan obviously the UK has a large
British Indian population so I do think
this is another attempt to kind of
localize the menu
that's pretty good that's pretty
flavorful there are some other main
course options from UK Ikeas which
unfortunately we couldn't find today
these include such things as butternut
squash and sweet potato soup Mangalore
chicken curry butternut squash blue
cheese and caramelized onion pie chili
sin carne garlic butter chicken pie
and leek and potato soup I would like to
move on to the sides right here we have
the vegetable
medallions I like veggies presented like
this just like in a little puck just
bite into it looks like it has some
broccoli mostly potato friendly a little
onion yeah not bad decent side it's like
you know it's like broccoli potatoes
like broccoli mashed potatoes The Havana
chicken that I mentioned earlier
this is the beans and rice it comes with
I don't know if they mix them up or just
got mixed up in transit but
no beans all right let's go this is just
white white rice and black beans like I
don't taste any additional flavor to
this at all they do sometimes offer
plantains again yeah Ikea we went to
today did not have plantains but they
did have a garlic bread
I think that's an exclusive on to the
IKEA cold dishes they have a veggie dog
well the veggie dog wrap is under the
cold dishes according to script and this
veggie dog is cold maybe it's been
sitting a while either way it's not very
good also they have a Greek salad I'll
say the Caesar salad which once again I
mean this is a pretty low effort a
Stockholm salad
uh not to be confused with Stockholm
syndrome which I'm starting to feel
right now eating this food salmon
lettuce
lemon
sure
that's that's not bad actually I like
this sauce that's turning color under
these lights and this salmon
we're not quite sure what is in this
salad with the sauces right now but do
the miracle of editing we can put that
on the screen right
and that's what it is tastes pretty good
also you get a BLT chicken wrap if you
like wraps and BLT and chicken also at a
US Ikea which is not available at time
of filming this at our Burbank IKEA is a
Greek veggie ball wrap and marinated
salmon the UK's cold Plate menu is
pretty bland in comparison the only one
they had today was this marinated salmon
plate but we can also get an egg and
shrimp sandwich with mayo marinated
salmon wrap small salad bowl and a
tomato and mozzarella salad I guess I'll
give the salmon a quick try I do like
smoked salmon here of course they call
it grab Lux because it's the traditional
Swedish way and it comes with a dill
sauce and some lemon fairly mild flavor
I like the kind of herb crusting that
you get
the dill sauce is pretty Dilly
and now on to desserts there are three
exclusive Ikea us desserts I was only
able to get one of them so the first
would be the Strawberry Shortcake not
available time of shooting this the
second is this the caramel almond cake
and the third is the infamous chocolate
layered cake also known as The
Conspiracy cake I asked everyone there
please tell me you have chocolate cake
and they all said no no chocolate cake
at the Burbank IKEA today at least
tragically we don't have the conspiracy
cake here in the UK but we do have some
other exclusive dessert options for
example this delightful looking
Strawberry Tart there's some real pieces
of strawberry in there I like the pastry
I like the cream I like the fresh
strawberries whatever kind of strawberry
syrup jelly stuff that they've kind of
put around the outside is it's okay but
it has like a slightly almost like
medicinal quality to it that I don't
really love it almost reminds me of a
calpol I don't know if you have that in
the US but it's like a medicine that's
marketed towards children in the UK next
up we have Ikea's famous dime cake now
you do have this on the menu in the US
however I believe you guys call it
something slightly different I think
caramel almond cake is dime not a
particularly big brand name in the US
because over here in the UK I'd say most
people are familiar with dime as a
chocolate brand uh Harry was just
talking a minute ago about the dime cake
the DM cake the aam cake I've never
heard of it I've never heard of that
brand I have no idea what it is I'm
sorry but we do have this which I think
is supposed to be similar
oh yeah this is fantastic I'm getting
one of these every time I go I'm gonna
get one of these and I'm gonna get the
chocolate cake I'm gonna get a lookout
for it now it's maybe not quite as
popular in the UK as it used to be it
reminds me of my granddad a lot because
he used to really love a dime bar I
wouldn't see many people my age going
for it but still very tasty if you're in
the mood for it and this cake is
Sensational you get these layers
of chocolate this kind of biscuity crumb
and these kind of like I've always
pancakes in the middle I think these
dividing lines might almost be kind of
cold chilled pancakes this might be my
favorite thing on the menu this is why
I'm making excuses to go to IKEA
they did have these at the register
and this also says dime on it you see
that yeah okay this tastes like this
never heard of this but it's very good
and this is fantastic maybe there's
rebranded it because no one in the US
knows what damn cake dime cake is our
next exercise option is a cheesecake
with blueberries and raspberries it's a
very soft cheesecake really like easy to
cut there's like a nice baked crumb on
top there's a layer of the berry stuff
so there's some blueberries in there
some raspberries then finally we have
these Under the Sea Rocky Road biscuits
obviously Rocky Road in the UK is a
dessert which is usually like a no-bake
dessert made of things like melted
chocolate golden syrup marshmallows even
things like corn flakes pieces of
biscuit that sort of thing all just kind
of mixed together left to set and then
you have a nice easy dessert it turns
out what makes this under the sea is
that they have a kind of animal stamp in
icing on top of it here we have this
nice octopus and here we have a couple
of dolphins
I think when I eat a rocky road I kind
of want some more distinct elements I
like being able to bite into it and
crunch through a bit of biscuit or chew
through a raisin or something or so this
one that's kind of all Blended together
so you don't really get the like texture
contrast the flavor is very much there
it's still all those elements that I'm
used to in terms of the flavor you may
also be able to find some other dessert
options on a UK menu which we couldn't
find today these include things like a
caramelized biscuit cheesecake a
chocolate Clementine bomb an elderflower
and lemon cake a gooey chocolatey cake a
lemon cheesecake rhubarb and custard
cake and a strawberry jelly aside from
this restaurant Ikea also has the
Swedish Bistro for quick Bites The
Bistro serves quick bites like hot dogs
and pizza slices that you can generally
grab on your way out of the store a few
exclusives we had of course was pizza
slice there it is
I went with cheese is is this like
Costco or like surprise
Ikea has amazing Pizza
this is a really good slice of pizza I
can't tell but I think this was a oven
cooked fire oven cooked not just like
the pizza this has like a
yeah there's a brick oven
it's not as good as Costco but it's
pretty good
wow weird Ikea's got good pizza good on
you Ikea you can also get this giant
Bistro pretzel
I didn't like a little braid here look
at me I'm a Jedi look you are not a Jedi
yet and it comes with mustard they
didn't have the mustard either man I
don't know is it because I went at 10 30
in the morning and this stuff hadn't
shown up yet
they didn't have anything
a pretzel with no mustard
well no
um
also the U.S Ikea Bistro you can get a
marinated salmon baguette they didn't
have it we have a few exclusive Bistro
options of Our Own in the UK firstly if
you like the onions on the hot dog you
can just get a side of fried onions next
up we have these which are chickless
strips so these are a plant-based
version of a chicken tender I'd say they
look pretty good they kind of pass the
visual test yeah when I tore this apart
I was worried that this actually wasn't
going to be right and unfortunately it's
not it's very spongy it's very mushy it
just needs a little bit more texture
it's just to make it resemble a chicken
tender a little bit more obviously when
you get an actual piece of chicken
tender or chicken breast you can kind of
tear it and you see those strips and the
fibers they just really haven't got that
hair flavor's not too bad though we can
also get chips from The Bistro in the UK
it doesn't seem like you guys can do
this in the US we have our veggie dog
option which comes with the same
toppings as the regular hot dog so here
we got fried onions you can also get
some with Pickles the veggie dog in the
UK isn't like a plant-based meat thing
it is just vegetables so it looks like
there's some kale in there some carrot
I'd like some mustard seeds I think that
with the fried onions with the pickles
and some sauce actually a pretty good
veggie option then we have some drink
options notably milkshakes in the UK you
can get milkshakes in four flavors
vanilla chocolate strawberry and banana
we've got a banana one today a little
sip
that's not bad pretty gentle banana
flavor it's mostly just ice cream but
with like a little bit of flavoring in
there which
who can who could say no Ikea in the UK
does serve breakfast although
unfortunately when we arrived today they
weren't serving it the options that
you'll find there are pretty much
everything that you would normally find
on a full English breakfast so it
includes things like bacon sausages hash
browns beans tomatoes mushrooms black
pudding sometimes you'll find things
like Patty scones as well and you can
also get white or wholemeal toast if
breakfast platters aren't your thing
then you can also just go for some fruit
or some porridge breakfast
The Breakfast Platter in the U.S also
comes in both regular and small sizes
and is made up of eggs potatoes bacon
Swedish pancakes and that's supposed to
be top of the lingonberry jam and then
give it to us the US breakfast menu also
offers a Skagen croissant sandwich which
is a croissant filled with traditional
Swedish shrimp salad and a half I think
Ikea has its own line of drinks
available in its restaurants the US
Ikeas you'll find Cola sugar-free Cola
sparkling raspberry juice lingonberry
juice and sparkling lemonade I went
ahead and got the Lincoln berry juice
straight up no idea what a linga bear is
but it's fantastic there's no difference
in the size cups you just have glasses
that are the same size or these to go
cups or whatever we have some drink
options at the restaurant in the UK that
you guys might not have in the US there
are a couple of options for kids which
are these pip organic juices we have a
couple of Robinsons options in the UK
Robinson's is probably the most popular
brand of squash in the UK and this is
basically just a diluted version of this
wash squash for those who don't know is
like a concentrated fruity drink that
you kind of water down to have a nice
refreshing beverage you can get a peach
and mango version or a raspberry and
apple version and if you feel like
celebrating any of your purchases that
you've just made from the Ikea you can
also get alcohol we have three alcoholic
options on the menu at the UK Ikea a
rose wine a red wine or a Dark Lager
finally Ikea has a Swedish Market where
you can buy pre-packaged food items to
take home the items on offer include
some of their classic foods like the
meatballs which you can buy frozen or
some gravy sachos which you can make at
home in the UK you can also find the
plant-based balls on offer in that you
can get a whole frozen dime cake which I
will be taking home and eating all by
myself and speaking of dime you can also
get the chocolate which the cake is
based on here it's in bite size form
rather than as actual chocolate bars but
as you can see it's chocolate with a
kind of hard caramel Center Charlie has
dibs on these another thing at the US
Ikea maybe not exclusives per se but of
course they have a whole thing a Frozen
stuff add a scrap stuff that was
interesting come on the cinema the
Cinnabons huh the cinnamon buns
meatballs and you know we were talking
about
the damn cake but um they do have it
Frozen
and take home and of course it is
let's compare the nutritional
information of some iconic Ikea dishes
in the US and the UK in the UK eight
Ikea meatballs contains the following
342 calories 25.1 grams of fat 8.2 grams
of carbs and 856 milligrams of sodium in
the US the same plate of Swedish
meatballs contain 304 calories 22.4
grams of fat 6.4 grams of carbs
592 milligrams of sodium the UK takes
this round in every category what about
the IKEA hot dog in the U.S it contains
260 calories 15 grams of fat 24 grams of
carbs and 780 milligrams of sodium I'm
in the UK the hot dog contains 293
calories 15.2 grams of fat 29.5 grams of
carbs and 708 milligrams of sodium looks
like the UK version is higher in
calories and fat once again USA Baby
what's actually in the iconic Ikea
meatballs according to the IKEA website
if you want to make their meatballs at
home use the following ingredients beef
mince pork mince onion garlic bread
crumbs milk egg and salt and pepper to
taste but these are actually the
ingredients list for proper Ikea
meatballs while on the back of the
Frozen packet
you'll find an ingredients list
according to this packet they contain
beef pork water breadcrumbs egg dried
onion salt egg powder black pepper
extract and allspice overall it seems
like it's pretty close to the list that
they gave you on the website with a few
more things like powdered ingredients
versus fresh ingredients and a couple of
spice differences too I wasn't able
to find it online or in the cafeteria
the ingredients list but I got here
the Frozen pre-cooked meatballs and
those ingredients actually not bad
assuming these are the ones they have in
the cafeteria in the U.S the ingredients
for this is Beef Pork water breadcrumbs
are made of unbleached wheat flour salt
yeast whole eggs salt dehydrated onion a
white that's not plural egg white
singular spices
that's not bad I think for a
pre-packaged product right it's like
well that's you know it's what's in them
right well we're on the subject of Ikea
ingredients one thing that UK viewers
might remember was our Infamous horse
meat scandal
back in 2013 a number of foods in the UK
claiming to be beef or pork were
actually found to contain traces of
horse meat while this wasn't necessarily
a health issue it did raise some major
questions concerning the traceability of
foods throughout Supply chains and
unfortunately Ikea was also caught up in
this Scandal Czech authorities found
traces of horse meat and some Ikea
meatballs that had been produced in
Sweden and shipped all around Europe
thankfully the horse meat meatballs were
found before they reach consumers in
total 760 kilograms of Meatballs were
destroyed given the fact that there's no
health concerns related to the
consumption of horse meat I think they
should have just leaned into it just
passed them off as like limited edition
horse meatballs and Just Go With It Lads
it's fine
Ikea's Food is Almost suspiciously cheap
it's actually one of the ways it tricks
you into spending more time and money in
its stores Ikea is basically willing to
take its losses with its cheap food
prices because that's counting on you to
spend a bunch of money on furniture and
other household items a former Ikea
executive even referred to the meatballs
as the best sofa seller in the UK a
plate of eight meatballs peas Mash or
chips gravy and lingerbread jam will set
you about just four pounds 95 at the
time of recording that's around 6.49 I
do have to say that's really cheap I
don't think the quality is that bad it's
really tasty food and yeah it's a real
bargain I will make an effort to go via
the restaurant if I'm just going through
Ikea even if I'm just popping in for
like one or two bits I'm gonna sit down
eat some plenty of Meatballs it's good
value it's tasty I love it an eight
meatball meal in the US is 9.99 which in
the UK is seven pounds 80. that's a 54
increase in the states
overall I would say Ikea is pretty
popular in the UK it's most people's
go-to for basic furniture and household
needs I would say especially when people
are buying a house or moving house or
something like that personally I love
Ikea I love going there I do enjoy a
trip it's fun I like the food I like
walking around and pretending like oh
that could be my apartment or my bedroom
or my kitchen I wouldn't say I carry
somewhere I go often particularly
because I live in quite Central London
and there aren't many in central London
I think they're trying to open one on
Oxford Street right now at the time of
recording this it wasn't open but
they're kind of trying to get there but
so like I say it's more of a place where
you'll go specifically when you need to
do an Ikea shop Ikea is so popular here
I think it's popular in the whole
country the one in Burbank we went there
10 30 in the morning it opens at 10 and
at 10 30. this parking lot was pretty
full the cafeteria line was full so I'd
say Ikea is pretty popular I personally
wouldn't go to IKEA just for the food
again it might be because I don't live
close enough to want to make that
worthwhile I do love the food the
meatballs are great like say the
desserts are fantastic but I don't like
it to the extent that I would make the
effort to travel to one just to either
I'm not gonna say I go to IKEA for the
food but the food definitely is a good
motivator to go to IKEA I will say
overall I do enjoy the experience of
going to an Ikea I am aware that it's
kind of designed to make us spend money
obviously the restaurant plays a part of
this as well because it's kind of
encouraging you to make a day of your
trip to Ikea really spend some time
there sit down take a break in the
middle of the day eat re-energize
yourself for more shopping and as you
can guess by my friends on the table
with me here I do think that their
marketing is a really clever ploy to
make us spend more money there as well
I'm joined here by my friend jungle skog
I'm really sorry I'm going to butcher
these pronunciations and uh my friend
who is the adorable little shark who is
also I think a trans icon love that
you'll often see things like this really
getting like a reputation on the
internet driving more Commerce to Ikea
stores I don't know if they're doing
that deliberately or if it's just kind
of like a side effect of making some
very very cute plush toys but everyone I
think will generally have at least one
thing from Ikea in their home so
whatever they're doing it's kind of
working I'm not mad about it either I
support Ikea keep up the good work guys
I have just been informed by my fellow
producer Yulie that they went on dates
at Ikea explain I'm gonna when
I didn't think that's a good way to get
to know someone's first you start eating
the food's Dirt Cheap so great okay
great and then you're walking around and
then be like this is the kind of couch I
like it's kind of art I like you're like
no no that huh if this goes and we're
thinking about it's going this is the
kind of bedroom setup they want and I
don't know and also if the person starts
like dogging like you see something that
you like and they start dogging on it
you're gonna be like that's not gonna
work out it's not gonna work out what
kind of could have weird or what's a
closet like this like I do take me home
but the date doesn't work that's like a
long walk out of there
yeah if you get to the uh the kids areas
I like the the kids stuff and the baby
stuff and if your partner's like I don't
want any of this crap you're like all
right we're not doing this then you're
walking I didn't that actually yeah it's
actually a good idea yeah all right a
date at Ikea I didn't think about that
it's actually pretty smart